تاتي زياره المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رفيق الجروسي الى طهران
وسطى استمرار الخلافات بين الوكاله وايران
وابرز هذه القضايا الخلافيه وجود ثلاثه
مواقع تقول الوكاله الدوليه انها تشتبه
بوجود انشطه مريبه فيها وهي تركوزا بارد
وهي قريه في محافظه طهران وموقع اباده في
محافظه فارس بالاضافه الى موقع في منطقه
ورامين جنوب شرقي طهران
منذ دخول معاهده حظر الانتشار النووي حيز
التنفيذ في عام 70 من القرن الماضي اصبحت
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ذراع الامم
المتحده للتحقق من البرامج النوويه
الوطنيه في جميع انحاء العالم من هذا
المنطلق باتت الوكاله بمثابه عيون واذان
المجتمع الدولي التي تراقب هذا البرنامج
منذ عام 2003 ومنذ توقيع الاتفاق النووي
عام 2015 اصدرت الوكاله تقارير عده تؤكد
التزام ايران بالاتفاق ظلت هذه التقارير
ايجابيه حتى بعد اعلان الرئيس الامريكي
دونالد ترامب في مايو ايار من عام 2018
خروج بلاده رسميا من الاتفاق النووي لكن
بعد مرور اكثر من عامين على خروج واشنطن
اعلنت الوكاله عدم رضاها عن تفسيرات ايران
لوجود جزيئات رونيوم عاليه التخصيب في
مواقعها
وفي عام 2021 جددت الوكاله القول ان ايران
فشلت في تقديم تفسير مقنع لوجود جزيئات
اليورانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه ومع
انتهاء مفعول اتفاق المراقبه بين ايران
والوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه في يونيو
حزيران من العام نفسه تشدد ايران على ان
هذه القضايا اغلقت بموجب الاتفاق النووي
وان اثارتها تصب في خانه الضغط السياسي
الغربي عليها